the world of science fiction is endless
and there's no shortage of new stories
to tell but sometimes the best sci-fi
stories on television are the ones
you've never heard of set the small
Germantown dark is a sci-fi thriller
where strange supernatural occurrences
have exposed secrets hiding than the
closets of several families honey hi
Grampy
more than living up to its title the
show includes scenes of adultery
kidnapping and homicide plus it's all
set against the backdrop of time travel
this Netflix series is a slow burn and
at times the physics of darks
time-travel can be a little hard to
follow but when it all comes into focus
the emotional impact of the larger
storyline is worth every second - the
journey into the future fans of Superman
will find many reasons to binge Syfy's
prequel series Krypton set to
generations before the destruction of
the Man of Steel's home planets the show
focuses on Superman's grandfather and on
the choices he must make to ensure his
grandson's future survival in its second
season Krypton started introducing some
DC fan favorites into the mix including
Lobo and intergalactic bounty hunter in
the same gritty vein as Marvel's
Wolverine and Punisher only much cooler
they stopped the making of bush
although most comic book geeks already
know how the story turns out sci-fi has
found a way to deliver enough surprises
to keep even the most hardcore super
fans guessing at what will happen next
the expanse is based on a series of
novels by James sa Corey and follows a
group of future anti-heroes and a space
colonized world on the verge of war
often compared to Battlestar Galactica
the expanse is a sort of space opera
that not only delivers a compelling
story but benefits from special effects
that don't feel like they belong on
basic cable luckily if you didn't get a
chance to catch the show before it was
cancelled by Syfy another network is
giving the series a second life
following a huge save the expanse social
media campaign Amazon stepped in and
picked up the show we just dodged a
massive bullet in Netflix is the society
a group of teens returned to their
hometowns to discover that it's been
mysteriously dropped into the middle of
nowhere with no adults no outside
resources and worst of all no internet
what nah come on thrown into a reality
where technology no longer exists these
teens not only need
to adapt they need to grow up far faster
than anyone should like a mash-up
between Lord of the Flies and lost the
Society says as much about humanity as
it does about technology the O AAA feels
like nothing else that's come before it
the show centers on a young woman who
reappears after having been kept in
captivity for seven years
but unlike most captives she has the
ability to travel through parallel
dimensions this supernatural sci-fi
thriller is packed with surprises from
questioning its main characters mental
states - throwing a huge curve ball at
the end of its sophomore run the Oh a is
taken nearly every twist and turn a
proper science fiction series can take
including a guest spot from a telepathic
octopus is this I just - lights bro
unfortunately future episodes won't be
twisting and turning on Netflix the
streaming service decided to end its
involvement with the series after its
second season but with a save vo a
campaign in full swing one never knows
when or where the show might resurface
despite a few surface similarities to
Rick and Morty final space is a show all
its own this animated sci-fi comedy on
Adult Swim is the demented brainchild of
olan Rogers with a little help from
executive producer Conan O'Brien it's
centered on the space Adventures of Gary
Godspeed and his planet destroying alien
friend moon cake along for the ride is a
ragtag group of intergalactic characters
ranging from a cat-like bounty hunter to
a robot companion voiced by Fred Armisen
hey Gary my name is Kevin I'm your deep
space insanity avoidance companion nice
to meet you I already hate you the
show's light-hearted tone perfectly
balances it's often thoughtful
storylines well it may take a few
episodes to sort things out it's worth
the trip and trip eNOS to see it through
imagine if The Chronicles of Narnia and
Harry Potter were written for adults the
results would be Syfy's than magicians
this intelligent fun and remarkably
relevant series deals with complex
themes while dropping pop-culture
references at every turn you watch
Battlestar Ryan yeah I love when they do
terrorism allegory when those who white
people it's from the creative mind of
Sarah gamble who spent over a decade on
the CW supernatural the overall tone of
the show is similar to supernatural but
the magician's deals with more adult
subject matter and it does so in a way
that's conscious and inclusive while
also throwing in the occasional epic
magic battle the premise of future man
sounds a lot like something that would
have been featured in a 1960s TV show an
underachieving janitor travels back in
time to save the world but in the hands
of Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg this
simple time-travel comedy turns into a
brilliant star-studded misadventure that
pays homage to our greatest sci-fi films
The Matrix Back to the Future Star Wars
Terminator Mad Max
despite the show's second season
receiving a 100% fresh rating on Rotten
Tomatoes
deadline announced in April 2009 that
future man would call it quits after its
third season on Hulu what future man
might soon be a thing of the past
it's guaranteed to go out with a bang
and just might save the world in the
process philip k dick Selectric dreams
features an approach to anthology
storytelling similar to black mirror
where the amazon series differs is in
its more optimistic outlook on the
future drawing from various short
stories by the man who
Blade Runner and the man in the high
castle electric dreams doesn't actually
believe the future is without hope
future ain't what it used to be
delivering stories that span vastly
different time periods the series
creates extraordinarily diverse settings
that explore technology and wildly
different ways the result is modern but
also tangible electric dreams feels like
a reality that could actually happen and
that isn't such a bad thing check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about sci-fi
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]